it's great to welcome to the program
today megan phelps roper who is author
of the book unfollow a journey from
hatred to hope leaving the Westboro
Baptist Church as the book's title
implies megan is a former member of the
Westboro Baptist Church Megan so great
to have you on I'm glad we finally were
able to do this finally I feel like
we've been talking by email since I was
still a member of the church so this is
the first time we've actually spoken
yeah yeah and for people I mean so
people may remember that years ago I
interviewed some other folks from the
Westboro Baptist Church some who are
biological relatives of yours some who
are not and who maybe we will we will
talk about but for people who aren't
familiar with you I mean what your your
childhood in Kansas what was it like
what's your first sort of memory of the
Westboro Baptist Church as what others
kind of know it to be I mean I was I was
five years old when we first started
protesting at a park about half a mile
from you know my house you know I lived
on the block that we know he's shared
with the church and several of their
family members or was a you know you
know fence and closing that whole area
so it for me that space was a refuge it
was you know it was filled with people
that I loved and who loved me and then
we would go out to these protests like I
said it's starting at this local park
and then branching out from there to be
basically you know everywhere outside of
the church anywhere outside the church
um was a legitimate target for our
protests and so we would go out there
and you know the day obviously there was
a lot of hatred on our signs we would
say that it was the hatred of God not
our own personal human hatred but the
hatred that was reflected back at us was
was ferocious you know people driving
their cars at us you know throwing
things coming after us on foot I mean I
it was it was not an uncommon thing for
a long time so these are these are my
earliest memories on the picket line as
far as you were concerned the the things
that you were protesting were and I mean
I guess the reason I asked that is the
outward facing side if people are
familiar
the protests they would say well these
are homophobic protests these are
protests that sometimes are against the
military they're religiously based
protests but like how did you conceive
of them from inside we saw it as loving
our neighbor we were going to warn
people of the consequences of their sins
which was an inherently loving thing
according to our understanding of the
Bible and that you know I was not an
incurious person I was not you know as
long as if there was a if we did
anything there had to be justification
from the Bible and as long as there was
you know I I was trained to believe that
that was the infallible Word of God and
it was unquestionable and I just I had
to go along with it any any thought or
feeling or doubt that I had was
indicative of a problem with me not with
the doctrine or with Westboro itself now
as you've talked about the fact that you
were doing this from such a young age
and maybe this became more of an issue
not when you were 5 but maybe more like
8 9 10 you had to start dealing with the
reaction from people in the community at
least to some degree did you have were
you sort of like prepared by others in
the church for that to happen and what
was the kind of preparation that you
were given or the defense that you were
given yeah we were absolutely prepared
and it was something that we we talked
about this every single day it looks
like you know sitting around our living
room with I'm the 3rd of 11 kids so we
would spend you know time every evening
reading the Bible memorizing Bible
verses you know honestly being on the
picket itself was preparation on the
picket line itself because you know
there you're encountering people who
obviously strongly disagreed with our
message and some were willing to you
know to articulate their positions and
in arguments and so we had to be ready
always you know and that's the buy mores
be ready always to give an answer to
every man that asks you a reason for the
hope that's in you with meekness and
fear so it was something that we took
deadly serious and and and I did too you
know we because we knew that the whole
world was against our message we needed
to be ready
with Bible verses you know in hand
memorized you can't you know pull out a
Bible and start looking things up when
you're standing there and somebody's
yelling in your face you have to be
ready immediately to give it you know to
both to exhort and to confuse the
gainsayers as my grams would say
according to Bible course and when this
happened and when people would either
challenge you on the the substance of
the protests or sometimes of course it
was it was not about the substance
necessarily but it was you you are all
terrible people you're doing something
that's horrible you're hurting other
people did you was do you recall that as
being traumatic in some sense or had you
been so prepared for it and sort of
equipped for it that you did not feel it
at least at the time as a traumatic
event I did not experience it as a
traumatic event and in fact I remember
one a moment early on when we were going
we were going to a protest that seemed
like it was going to be particularly
acrimonious acrimonious and possibly
even dangerous and and I was I was
really small and I remember and maybe I
was just being melodramatic you know
it's probably five or six and and I kind
of whimpered a little bit and you know I
think it was my mom who it was my mom
who was like basically cut that out with
us I experienced you when people would
accuse us of being hateful like I knew
that my intentions were not hateful I
knew that I was trying to to do the
right thing no to do you know Gramps
would say that you know the world needs
this message more than they need food to
eat air to breathe air water to drink
and know I can I believe that and so
when I just I basically just felt
misunderstood you know these people are
making all these accusations but that's
just because they don't understand God
has blinded them really we're the good
guys and and they they just don't get it
and you at least at this point that
we're talking about right now you were a
hundred and ten percent behind that as
the interpretation of what was going on
at this point there was not the doubt
that later started to surface right
absolutely
I was I was all in at this point and
when we talk
when I say your family people may not
know your mom is Shirley phelps-roper
and then fred phelps your grandfather
was your family sort of loving and it
other than this which to the outside
appears to be a really horrible thing to
expose a kid to but from the perspective
from within the church it was it was a
loving thing to warn people and to save
people other than that what is your
experience now having seen the way other
people were raised and live in the world
was it one of sort of like a loving
household in the traditional
stereotypical ways I would say there's
there's there's two parts to him you
know there is absolutely it was full of
love and care and and you know I I think
of my parents and you know the I'm
overwhelmed with those positive memories
and the time that we spent together and
yes absolutely you know reading I mean
other than the Bible even reading
together my dad would you know I the way
that my dad did bedtime when I was a kid
I mean it's just it's just all these you
know wonderful memories but then of
course you know though the that hardline
biblical stance but that we took toward
outsiders that absolutely applied to us
inside as well you know we were held to
an extremely high particular set of
standards and any deviation from that
was caused for for punishment and when I
was younger that absolutely included
physical punishment and and I would even
say abuse not it wasn't every single
time but it absolutely did you know
frequently enough therein to abuse
at least in my family and and I know
that it was you know that what I
experienced was far less extreme even
than what my mom and her generation
experienced right so there there was
that side of it and there was you know
the the absolute terror that you feel of
going to hell of what God is going to do
to you if you don't 100% toe the line on
everything when I say everything I
really mean everything it could come
down to a look on your
face or a tone in your voice those kinds
of things could get you into deep
trouble and it's one of those things
that you know since I left you know the
relief that I feel at not having this
sort of constant attribution of ill
motives for you know any possible you
know it just seemed like by the time I
left my sister and I my sister grace
left with me by the time we left you
know the way we the way we would
describe it we would say everything that
looks bad is bad and everything that
looks good is also bad it's just this
this there there is this wonderful sense
of I'm sorry I'm going on here but
there's an amazing sense of community
and togetherness in in groups like
Westboro but there's also the
understanding you know the high high
cost of daeviation of any of any sort so
you and grace eventually left but let's
let's build up to that where first of
all that by the time you started
experiencing some doubts or questions I
would love for you to tell us when that
was and what prom you did but were there
other siblings or cousins or whoever
that had also already left at the point
at that point yes so my brother Josh
he left when I was 18 and he was 19 so
my but he was the first person close to
me who left the church I had heard about
my you know siblings of my mother's who
had left and they were just understood
to be hell bound and hated by God and
and just essentially disposable like you
understand that people who leave are
their disposable you just you just
they're not our family anymore you know
there's a passage where Jesus says who
is my mother and who are my brother and
these that do the will of God so the
people in the church were our family and
everyone outside of that was not right
so and yes I mean I so there there were
others there were cousins other cousins
who had left as well and so I had these
examples but they were not you don't
take them as an example to follow you
take them you take them as an example of
what you want to avoid there's actually
almost the opposite effect it's not
something like when somebody leaves
that's close to you you don't feel like
you want to follow them you feel like
you want to
you need to prove yourself it's almost
like you throw yourself even more deeply
into the work of the church to prove
that you're not like them that sings and
is that what was there an air did you
feel as though when someone would leave
that there would be an air of suspicion
that would be upon you and others yeah
yeah and and not just suspicion but just
worried you know and I needed to show
people that you know in fact I went and
looked up you know when my cousin Livvy
left I'd been you know pretty close to
her and and I went and looked up you
know the email that I sent afterwards
the whole church basically you know I
feeling the need to say bad things about
her and to show that I was not on the
same page with her rebellion
so yeah you asked a question though
about yes oh well so that's it I mean so
that gets us to what you had observed in
terms of people separating while you
were still there and I mean I guess I'd
be I want to hear a little bit about
what started the questions and yet the
doubts and the sort of looking into
other worldviews right so I got on
Twitter in 2009 and I didn't go on
Twitter because I was looking to have my
mind changed I got on Twitter to spread
West Bros message I remember when that
happened in fact and if correct me if
I'm wrong it wasn't just you but there
were a couple of your sisters who were
maybe also doing the same I was the only
one tweeting publicly for a while okay I
feel like it was maybe maybe about a
year something like that yeah and then
yes absolutely a bunch more people got
on my mom got on she was at dear surely
Margie yeah and then I think some of my
uncles and and others also so yeah but
and you know when again when I got on I
wasn't trying to I was just trying to
show other people while they were wrong
why they were wrong and how and but over
time you know several things happen
there were a lot of things about Twitter
that that were really powerful to me
first of all like the first thing and
this was the I think the one thing that
I was conscious of was that with only
140 characters you know there wasn't
space for the kind of insults that we
just you know threw around all the time
like you know if you remember that era
but it was constant yeah I mean I
remember when Margie called me a
titmouse which might have had some I
mean that one's pretty short and pithy
a lot of them were much more involved
and required you know sort of being able
to be could be a little bit more verbose
yes and so my mom every time basically
every time she would like George W Bush
was the president at the time so she
would say bombastic blowhard bigmouth
bastard okay uh and so like this was for
that on Twitter and then I realized that
even when there even when there was
space even if when I did make the space
for it you know and I would watch the
conversation immediately just go off the
rails and we're no longer talking about
this theological point that I feel is so
important now it's this person being
defensive because I've called them a
stupid name right and so you know I did
so I learned not to do that that was the
first kind of step I think for me away
but I mean that was just a different
slightly different communication style
yeah I mean I guess that opened the door
to at least interacting with people in a
different way you still have your view
they still have theirs they're wrong
you're right but at least the method of
communication has shifted a little bit
slightly exactly yeah but then you know
so then one of the first people that I
attacked when I got on Twitter was this
guy David Abbott ball who ran a blog
called chew licious and you know I only
attacked him because because he was
Jewish because you know Jews killed
Jesus sure as you know as I've been told
many times and so anyway so he um he
initially responded like many other
people just like full of hostility and
then but pretty quickly he recognized he
said later you recognize that I was
sincere and that he thought it was
important to articulate you know why why
have we as a society rejected messages
like Wes burrows for the people who were
following both of us who would see both
of us he thought it was important to
offer a counterpoint so he wasn't even
necessarily at first trying to reach me
specifically and so but you know getting
so over time of a row buddy here we're
having these conversations where he's
asking me questions about our picket
signs and I'm asking him questions about
Judaism and Jewish theology Trump and
the only reason I'm asking is I want to
find better ways of countering his
points but he was the first person you
know after that you know about a year of
conversation who found the first
internal inconsistency in westeros
doctrine and
for me like that was absolutely the
moment that was the beginning of the end
and what was an inconsistency it was
actually one eye I realized this morning
because I went back looking at fur there
was a couple of videos interviews that
you had done that I wanted to like what
am I remembering this correctly so I
wouldn't looked up a couple of them and
you you you mentioned it he mentioned
the death penalty for you know the sign
calling cause the death penalty for gays
and you know it that was the you know
point that David mean you know I'm
saying what you know my uncle said to
you if that punishment is good enough
for God then it's good enough for us
that's right the mosaic code calls for
and so therefore you know that that's it
that's that's the standard and David
said well didn't Jesus say let he who is
without sin cast the first stone
you didn't mention that you mentioned
the other point that David made which
was you mentioned my mom you know had my
oldest brother out of wedlock and we had
answers to both of those arguments when
somebody would say you know what he was
without sin cast the first stone we
would say we're not casting stones we're
preaching words and David again you know
points out the obvious response to that
which is yeah but you're advocating that
the government cast stones and you know
who were there is sinless and then also
you know the point about my mother like
we would always say you know she
repented of that sin and so therefore
she doesn't deserve that punishment but
of course again if you kill somebody as
soon as they sin then they don't have
the opportunity to repent and be
forgiven if you just you know and so I
realized of course if my mother had been
killed my family wouldn't exist the
hypocrisy of it was so apparent to me
and so yeah it just was I didn't know
what to make of it you know I decided to
stop holding that sign I went to my
mother and a couple of the older people
in the church and and asked about this
and was just told that you know I was
getting wrapped around an axle and the
point is they're not going to institute
the death penalty and and I just like
you know if we were making this a litmus
test why why is that you know why isn't
the fact that they're not doing it like
actually what you know doing what Jesus
said not having you know trying to kill
people for their sins
giving them the opportunity to repent
and be forgiven so that what for me that
that was the first time I realized that
we could be wrong you know I believed
before that all my life there had always
been an answer you know something
something from the Bible that would
explain our position and so yeah it's
just my bling for me so what how long
did that so that was maybe the catalyst
and then it continued how long did the
process take while you were still in the
church but increasingly questioning okay
so it was that was I think November of
2010 that conversation with David it was
July of 2012 when I finally finally had
this realization but like oh my god what
if we're just people what if this isn't
the place led by God himself
and and then it was another four months
after that before I actually the day I
actually walked out the door like I had
you know in that time that four-month
period I kind of was going back and
forth between thinking you know am I am
I crazy like I I kind of thought you
know this was Satan whispering in my ear
it was it was a test from God that I was
failing and but then also you know
understanding like you know going
through all these questions and doubts
in my mind and realizing like no this is
absolutely wrong this cannot be right
and so I I've interviewed a lot of
former Scientologists and when they
described leaving they talked about
there are physical impediments to doing
that sometimes it involves escaping
sometimes it involves all sorts of
physical stuff in your case it was
different I mean it was a different
leaving means something different in
your case yep absolutely I mean there is
no they would say this is a volunteer
army right this isn't we're not we don't
want anybody here who doesn't want to be
here so if you don't want to be here you
just need to leave you know my parents
helped me pack it was not for Westboro
you know there are there are definitely
aspects of Westboro that are cult-like
this is one where it's not you know
they're they're not trying to force
anyone's hand yeah you know physically
speaking they will use all kinds of you
know threats of eternal torment and you
know obviously the the shunning process
so just common to basically every cult
that has ever existed
but they're not trying to physically
stop people from leaving and when you
say that this is what you're doing
what's the conversation is it we're not
going to be in touch anymore is it I
mean how does that sort of go you just
you just understand you know that when
people leave you know that there that
there is no contact there you know I
would occasionally when I was a member
of the church like somebody would ask me
well like what if you saw so-and-so
ex-member out in the grocery store
whatever like what would you say to them
and I just could draw nothing but a
blink like what what everything's been
said there's nothing left to say this
person is hellbound they've rejected God
and that's all there is to it
there is never any sense at Westboro
that there is there's no legitimate
reason to leave ever even even if we if
and when they come to recognize that
they were wrong about something they
will never acknowledge that as a reason
to leave although they will look at
every other church and say well you saw
that XYZ was wrong like why don't you
leave immediately you knew too that
couldn't be a godly place because they
were they had this simple doctrine but
they'll never recognize that in
themselves and so X members are just
again totally disposable so you left as
you mentioned earlier with one of your
sisters was that I mean what how much
planning and conversation with her sort
of goes into it that was absolutely
terrifying you know cuz no par as I know
no one has ever like everybody's always
left alone you know you understand that
you know you can't trust anybody else
you know you can't you know they they
are supposed to you know according to
this passage in Deuteronomy you know if
you go to somebody and say let us go and
serve other gods right this that I don't
I don't think this is right
they're the ones who are supposed to
turn you in for stoning of course again
you know westeros not gonna be actually
starting people but but that you know
the the implication there the
understanding that if you go and talk to
somebody about any of these things that
they're supposed to turn you in or not
they're not supposed to hide you and so
anyway so for me to go to my sister you
know I felt like I had to because I had
been
talking with her about some of these
doubts and never to the extent of
actually doubting Westborough itself but
you know we talked about it and she was
the only person who gave any quarter to
the idea that that we could be wrong
about anything and I just I felt like I
had to talk to her before before leaving
and so it was like I said it was those
four months we were kind of going back
and forth you know I wanted to talk
about all the things that I knew were
wrong I had come to believe along I was
I knew that I was not gonna protest any
more funerals I was not gonna pray for
her any more people to die
I'm provide things to happen to others I
know I wasn't gonna hold certain signs
that I then believed or unscriptural but
I wanted to focus on those things and my
sister wanted to focus on what it was
going to cost us what it was gonna mean
to leave and so in that time you asked
about preparation you know we were doing
all these things so you know taking
photos and voice recordings and
collecting family recipes and copying
dozens of DVDs worth of home movies and
you know all these things that we would
forever lose access to once we left you
know asking my parents about how they
met and this whole you know just all
these questions that you would never I
just never thought really to really dig
into and so we were doing all those
things and but part of it was absolutely
a stalling tactic you know maybe during
this time we you know we're asking
questions and trying to you know very
gently change people's minds from the
inside and just being met over and over
again it was like hitting a brick wall
again and again nothing was changing um
but we kept hoping that it would and the
first I don't know couple of weeks
couple of months after you left I mean
what was your time mostly sort of
consumed by the first month my sister
was still in school so we moved to
Lawrence Kansas to live with another ex
member one of my cousins and my sister
was commuting four days a week to Topeka
it was half an hour away for her classes
so it was just I think full of just
logistical like how do you live outside
of Westboro and also a lot of a lot of
fear there was I mean
I basically what I kind of at that point
still believed in hell I still believed
that God was gonna you know maybe strike
me down I'm getting some awful car
accident or happening to some other kind
of you know you know my mom would say
that the weapons and God's Arsenal are
innumerable and I believe that so I
would have these like visions of these
terrible things happening to me for a
long time after I left I would say I
mean probably for the first year and
then after that first month my sister
when I decided to run away to South
Dakota and read books we went to
Deadwood South Dakota we basically at
that point were we're just we realized
we were still running into our family
all the time in Topeka you know driving
by protest at the grocery store just
everywhere
and so we realized we needed to get away
so we drove 12 hours to Deadwood South
Dakota and brought a bunch of books
because we were trying to basically
build a worldview from scratch like what
if Westboro isn't true if the Bible
isn't everything you know then you've
got a lot of catching up to do so to
speak absolutely absolutely so so and
there was there was so much you know in
that you know I've talked about this
moment you know being in the public
library in Lawrence Kansas and just
looking up with these stacks of
philosophy books and this wave of kind
of humiliation and shame washing over me
I'm like how had we ever believed that
we alone had had the truth and everyone
else was wrong and to believe that so
confidently and to have no question
about it
you know Gramps would say this you know
about how there's something liberating
about being a hundred percent right
there was never any question in our
minds and how how could we have thought
that any way there so there's it was but
but very shortly like while I was in
Deadwood it was about less than two
months after I left I saw this hash I
had largely at that point I had been
super active on Twitter and I had
stopped after that moment in July of
2012 and this this hash tag appeared you
know where is Meghan phelps roper and
you know these people like you know
people who hated Westborough who hated
my family - taunting them on Twitter you
know saying you know sending people in
topeka like to the picket line and to
drive by my house to see if my car was
there and you know it felt like to me it
felt like being hunted and like I had to
you know face this past that I still
didn't understand that I was trying to
figure out like I come to believe that
we were wrong but I didn't understand
you know what was right or what what I
was supposed to do about any of it and
you know it was it was terrifying so I
you know three months after I left I put
out this statement basically um and did
one interview and then you know
basically saying I did everything that I
did because I thought I was right I
thought I had to I thought it wasn't you
know I thought this was the most
important thing in the world um I've
come to believe that that's wrong and
here are some reasons why and I hope
that what I do from now on and the way
that I live from now on um the changes
that I make in my life will will speak
for themselves so it's been seven years
now since you left is that right yeah in
that time what degree of contact if any
have you had with people that are still
part of the church almost none I mean I
said I reach out to them regularly I'm
just to be clear like I I know that I
was changed by outsiders the kindness
and compassion and gentle persuasion of
outsiders and I know that you know I
have a friend who basically said you
know they have demonized you more than
you know that ex-members they demonize
ex-members more than anyone else the
likelihood that you are gonna be the
voice they get through to them is
extremely small and and I think she was
trying and I'm glad she said it it was
one of those things that you know I
immediately felt immense resistance to
you know because I realized I didn't
want to I didn't want to not reach out
to them I didn't want to not try to fail
to try seemed like like giving up you
know and I didn't I didn't I didn't I
didn't want to do that I will I still
love them you know dearly
I think that they are deeply misguided
and have heard a lot of people and you
know taught me to do the same thing and
I obviously that's wrong and but I don't
think that isolating them or just going
on with my own life that changes nothing
for them and and so so I started
reaching out to them my sister and I
both did and you know initially partly
just you know to tell them that we loved
them and but then all again almost
immediately though it was it became
about trying to make arguments that they
could hear to change their minds to help
them moderate their positions in some
way and so that has been and I
occasionally get responses largely it's
on Twitter you know recently um you know
one of the things that I have talked
about is is how unscriptural our funeral
protests were you know things like you
know the Apostle Paul saying to the week
I became as weak that I might gain the
week that's not what we did we went to
the week and we we danced on the
American flag we played flag soccer
we sang happy birthday September 11 as
these mourners are walking by sometimes
just a few yards away like that was not
to the week I became this week that is
not speaking the truth in love and in
many other passages and I actually got
my my uncle recently on Twitter just to
acknowledge that that kind of spiteful
joy he says spiteful joy is never wrong
but he won't actually acknowledge that's
what they were doing he won't say they
will not actually apologize they will
not repair those breeches that they made
and into - but I I again that's another
thing that I hope to convince them to do
eventually so I mean as far as the of
course you've said that the specific
beliefs that were being espoused through
the protests you you don't believe
you've distanced yourself from what are
your religious views now like you still
consider yourself a Protestant Christian
to some degree no not at all I am not
religious at all anymore I mean I still
I still read the Bible but it's not it's
not because I believe that it has all
the answers you know to every question
that might you know be in the universe
but just
because one I mean it's everywhere you
know it's the Bible is quoted in all
kinds of literature like I think that
there are a lot of wonderful things in
the Bible there's also a lot of really
terrible things in the Bible sure and I
now no longer I don't accept the good
I mean accept the bad because of the
good or rejection the good because of
the bad like my TED talk a couple years
ago the thrust of that talk was
essentially love your enemies from Jesus
as far as I mean I'm curious about your
perception you know i I've stopped
interviewing the people from the church
several years ago people have asked me
why and I said well listen every
everything is a balance of is if it's a
bad idea is it prominent enough that
it's worth fighting and otherwise we may
just be better off not paying attention
to it my perception is that the amount
of attention that the church gets that
its prominence has been significantly
diminished since the time that you left
and so I've made the call that I don't
think there's really much to gain by
doing the interviews but is my is your
sense that my perception is correct that
the church is significantly diminished
from where it was a decade ago
absolutely
yeah there's any question about that I
think part of it is a result of the fact
that they have moderated in some ways
it's also partly because you know the
like I mean a lot of their new signs are
things like you know racism is a sin or
be reconciled to God so any sign that in
any hand holding those signs is not
holding you know God hates [ __ ] there's
a right if not those signs are all gone
but a lot of them are like I mean they
that's one of things I mentioned the
pray for more dead soldiers pray for
more dead kids those signs aren't aren't
out there anymore either so a lot of the
things that they were doing that got
them so much attention um they're either
not doing or or but also I feel like
there's you know somebody else pointed
out there's just so much hatred in the
world right now so put the polarization
and the you know inability to to
converse across ideological lines like
has just massively increased the amount
of hatred and so it's the press in a
sense that there's been so much course
sinning of the political discourse that
I mean of course the messages are still
absolutely horrible from the Westboro
Baptist Church to the extent that
they're the same messages from before
but the fact that it's less unique as
completely course in political discourse
is in a sense extremely disturbing it is
it really is and that's you know
somebody I saw somebody call it the
Westboro ization of politics and I think
that's true so act you know Westboro
itself has actually kind of gotten lost
in the middle of that you know again
which again it's it's really sad I think
you know I've been doing you know
whatever I can to encourage people to to
not give in to those impulses to you
know try to shame people and and shame
is a really powerful tool I want to be
clear like I understand shame is a
powerful tool and and then it does work
in certain situations right so I've been
talking lately about I was talking to an
anthropologist last year who defines
shame as the feeling we get when we have
violated the norms of our community and
you know that's that's the key that last
part the norms of our community when we
have we have the tribalism in this
country right now we are so divided that
we we see the shaming of people on the
other side like we take that as a badge
of honor just like we didn't whisper oh
it was something that you know it was it
was proof of our righteousness if these
evil people think that we're wrong and
and you know like that that's something
that shows that we're right and so it
wasn't shame that changed me it was
again the compassion and empathy of
people who took the time to try to
understand where I was coming from who
made me feel heard and and who were able
to you know find these internal
inconsistencies and you know build
rapport over time yeah my audience will
probably be almost sick of me saying
this at this point but whenever I talk
to someone that left any kind of hate
group or extremist groups sometimes
they're called sometimes they're not the
number one thing that they cite as what
could have number one prevented them
from getting sucked in in the first
place for people who were recruited not
for people who were born into something
or what was most responsible for getting
them out was people outside of their
ideology being empathetic
and it might come with facts in some
cases but what's clear is that just
beating people over the head with the
facts alone seems very ineffective it
yeah no absolutely and that was one of
the things like we haven't talked about
this yet but I think I did mention this
to you once your show is actually
inadvertently responsible or indirectly
responsible for my marriage yeah I love
her to go to that next and it's good yet
I we emailed about this a couple years
ago and I've fortunately I don't
remember the details so there'll be sort
of new to me as you tell them now what
is that connection so when you had my
mom on the show in I think it was
February of 2011
I'm sure it was February 2011 and and
anonymous Jake Davis who has been known
as topiary Robin you had him on and they
took over Westeros website and that
became it was it was a huge I mean I
don't know how much I can't bring
exactly how many views you got on that
video it's gotta be six or seven million
at this point yeah it was insane I know
it happened so fast and so that became
this international news story and it
ended up in the RSS feed of this man in
eastern South Dakota who sent me a
message on Twitter that was initially
you know again kind of he said nasty or
crude I responded you know flippantly
kind of the way I always did it and and
that started a conversation like he he
was impressed with my grammar but yeah
and so he was anonymous for the first
like seven months we were talking this
is actually all this is all part of the
book but yeah you know we'd start
playing weird to the friends use us and
all these questions about the church
he's a lawyer you know like my family so
yeah you know it was right around the
time we won that US Supreme Court case
Snyder V Phelps and so yeah Jay started
these conversations and he was one of
those voices his arguments were not you
know logical theological they were more
about there were emotional arguments you
know I would be talking about and and
for him feed the funeral protests and
celebrations of death and tragedy he
just could not get past you like you're
recording all these things in the Bible
and I'm looking them up I see that
they're there but I cannot imagine going
to these families and telling them you
know while they're burying their child
to pray for more dead kids I don't I
don't
and I don't understand how that's how
that's biblical or how that's right
so anyway that and then you know
eventually you know after seven months I
have this dream about you know meeting
him and in the dream I embrace him and I
wake up from that dream realizing like
oh my god I can never talk to this
person again
so I you know cut off communication with
him and then I left I ended up leaving
it was a year later about a year later
um anyways when I met him and he was
just as great in person yeah that is
compressing an incredible story in the
last and we met and were together and
now we have we have a daughter that
that's an incredible story well to the
extent that I played a positive role in
it I that's a good thing I mean what
what else could it accidentally I guess
we would say right yeah absolutely it
was really cool cuz I met topiary Jay
Davis like he eventually was like
arrested and charged yes UK he was
something unrelated to hacking the West
yeah absolute ease of his and but yeah
it's like it's so cool meeting these
people who had this you know obviously
again I know you didn't you didn't mean
for it to happen but no I'm so grateful
your show exists thank you well listen I
really appreciate your time I want to
tell everybody to get the book unfollow
a journey from hatred to hope Megan was
kind enough to send me a PDF a couple of
weeks ago and I got through as much of
it as I could before the interview and I
I will absolutely be finishing it we've
been speaking with megan phelps roper
megan i really appreciate your time and
it's so great that we were finally able
to do this yeah thank you so much for
having me